[Musique]
le conseil constitutionnel nous a
proclamé élu président de la république
ensuite le seul souverain c'est le
peuple c'est pas qu'on sait qu'on se
diffusa vous passez votre temps à
essayer de renier le conseil
constitutionnel général de gaulle
dirigeait le conseil constitutionnel il
prenait 5 décision par an donc ce
n'était pas vraiment le burn out
aujourd'hui le conseil constitutionnel
en sans décision rend c'est
incontestablement une avancée l'état de
droit
[Musique]
vous connaissez vous le conseil
constitutionnel moi pas vraiment je sais
juste que c'est l'un des plus audacieux
est aussi une des plus discrètes
[Musique]
le conseil est logé dans une aile du
palais royal bord dans ses magnifiques
jardins face au ministère de culture et
à côté comédie française si vous
autorisation accordée j'entre superbe et
majestueuse ce cahier
dorures plafond le lieu magnifique
prêterait contemplation
et non pourtant ici c'est le temple de
la loi et même de la loi des lois la
constitution de la vème république
neuf sages sont chargés de la faire
respecter
chaque jeudi matin le conseil se réunit
en majesté autour de son président
laurent fabius pour décider si une loi
récemment votée par le parlement est
conforme ou non à cette constitution
c'est ce que l'on appelle à délibérer et
ses secrets
charlie l'huissier referment les portes
napoléon sur moi
avec ma caméra nous sommes priés
d'attendre dehors certes on me prête une
ville intérieure mais moi je trouve cela
un peu long secret pourquoi secret
pourquoi ces secrets parce que c'est
considéré je pense que c'est à raison
comme une protection de notre
indépendance
précis on ne peut pas faire pression sur
nous on ne sait pas comment monsieur x
madame y s'est prononcé on le saura 25
ans plus tard lorsque les archives de
nos délibérés puisque tout est pris en
note seront rendus publics et c'est
intéressant pour les juristes à ce
moment là mais il est très important que
nous soyons indépendants de tous les
pouvoirs
grand retour en arrière 1958 la tfm
république vit ses dernières heures
instaurée pour reconstruire le pays
après le terrible seconde guerre
mondiale elle ne résiste pas aux crises
régime parlementaire le pouvoir est
détenu par l'assemblée nationale du
gouvernement sont donc le fruit de
combinaisons au partizan alliance de
circonstance un régime de parti
forcément instable or dans les années 50
les guerres d'indochine et d'algérie
déchire profondément l'opinion et les
parlementaires les gouvernements sont
renversés les uns après les autres au
printemps 58 c'est le 22e depuis la
libération je sais par expérience que
nos institutions
tout va pas
[Musique]
en désespoir de cause le président de la
république rené coty en appelle à
l'homme providentiel du 18 juin le
général de gaulle
l'idée est mon gouvernement avance hiv
[Applaudissements]
assurer le mandat exceptionnel
établir un projet de constitution
nouvelle et de le soumettre à la
décision du pape la suite c'est un
référendum pour dire oui ou non à la
nouvelle république la 5e et à sa
nouvelle constitution alors oui non oui
non oui c'est le oui qui l'emportent
au texte
formalité qui donne force de loi à la
constitution y porte 25 signature celle
du président coty du général de gaulle
et celle des 23 min ce l'exemplaire tiré
sur parchemin ouvert ring est aussitôt
entré dans une vitrine la vème
république est entré dans l'histoire
mais au fond c'est quoi une constitution
la constitution c'est la loi
fondamentale qui fixe l'organisation et
le fonctionnement de l'état le général
de gaulle qui n'avait pas vraiment le
régime des partis sans détailler une à
son image un pouvoir exécutif fort
instabilité gouvernementale et la
création d'une justice constitution
enfin presque un conseil constitutionnel
neuf sages désigné pour devant et pour
quoi faire pour le comprendre je vais à
la rencontre de dominique schnapper
ancienne sage et première sociologue
avoir siégé rue de montpensier je suis
obsessionnel tout court il y en aura pas
d'autre le premier sujet alors ce qui
est des générations ne n'est pas connu
mais c'est comme çà ne vous échappe pas
mais ça a commencé comme un club oui de
politique âgé de notes il fallait
qu'ils fallaient casey et d'ailleurs il
avait très peu de rôles le général de
gaulle dirigeait le conseil
constitutionnel il avait nommé un
ambassadeur comme président qui n'avait
pas de compétence spéciale en droit
public qui était un fidèle qui suivaient
les décisions du général de gaulle avec
cet argument tout à fait étonnant quand
même étant donné qu'il a écrit la
constitution je ne vais pas là lui
opposer ce qui était vraiment une très
curieuse conception de l'état de droit
le conseil constitutionnel du temps du
général de gaulle cac les conséquences
qu elle était considérée comme je cite
le chien de garde de l'exécutif l'idée
était il y avait une majorité gaulliste
parlement à l'assemblée en tout cas mais
si la majorité est gaulliste voter
quelque chose qui n'était pas tout à
fait conformes à ce que souhaitait
l'exécutif à ce moment là il fallait que
le conseil consiel puisse censurer un
vrai chien de garde d'ailleurs
mitterrand dans son fameux pamphlet le
coup d'état permanent en 1964 n'aura pas
de mots assez durs pour qualifier le
conseil il dit c'est la cour suprême du
musée grévin un vrai garçon course du
général de gaulle tout est dit ou
presque
il avait d'abord été conçu comme le
gardien de la répartition des
compétences entre le parlement et le
gouvernement
pour être sûr que les partis ne
reprennent pas le pouvoir qu'ils avaient
sous la quatrième république d'où un
rôle important du conseil qui consistait
à vérifier que le parlement ne
reprennent pas plus de pouvoirs que la
constitution
ne lui en lui en accorder justement
parce qu'on pensait qu'il ne serait pas
très occupée par cette mission lui en
avait confié d'autres par exemple le
fait de veiller à la régularité
du référendum de l'élection
présidentielle le fait aussi d'être le
juge on oublie mais c'est quelque chose
de très particulier et très
inhabituelles dans les régimes
parlementaires le fait d'être le juge
des élections législatives et
sénatoriales
donc finalement sa compétence était plus
un patchwork autre chose en 1958
patchwork macramé un conseil disons le
fort peu occupés qui ne se réunisse et
qu'une dizaine de fois par an à 180
milles 180
1776 mais en 1974 valéry giscard
d'estaing juste élu président révise la
constitution un séisme une révolution
juridique pour le conseil
constitutionnel
avant 1974 seul pouvait doux saisir le
président la république le premier
ministre le président du sénat y
présente assemblée et en 1974 monsieur
giscard d'estaing a fait voter une
réforme très importante dix ans non
c'est pas simplement ses quatre
autorités qui peuvent saisir le conseil
mais ce sont
au moins soixante députés ou 60
sénateurs alors qu'est ce que ça change
c'est que désormais l'opposition où les
oppositions peuvent saisir le conseil
constitutionnel et donc ceux ci fixe est
beaucoup plus démocrate et l'opposition
ne peut pas se contenter de contester un
texte pour des motifs politiques il faut
trouver des arguments juridiques et des
arguments constitutionnels ça a
contribué on le dit moi mais à ce que
les parlementaires s'approprie davantage
le texte de la constitution puisque
finalement y compris lorsqu'ils
élaborent la loi lorsqu'ils ont des
battes et qu'ils la votent et bien la
préoccupation constitutionnel était du
fait de cette réforme beaucoup plus
présente dès la fin des années 70 dans
leurs discussions conséquence directe
depuis cette réforme le conseil
constitutionnel a été saisi près de 800
fois par le parlement et près de 800
fois rendu des décisions la loi peut
être déclarée conforme censuré
partiellement ou non ces décisions
accompagne les évolutions de la société
française liv et g en 75 au fort les
nationalisations voulu par la gauche en
82 cents soit partielle les
privatisations de la droite 86 censure
partielle aussi
nationalisation privatisations tout les
deux sens sur m et pourquoi
en fait ce qui est intéressant quand on
regarde de loi qui ont pour objet de
faire rigoureusement linverse l'une de
l'autre on s'aperçoit que le conseil
constitutionnel
conserve une lecture strictement
juridique de la situation et donc il ne
va pas du tout rentrer dans le débat
politique pour ou contre les
nationalisations les privatisations et
finalement il va rechercher si le droit
de propriété privée de ceux dont on a
nationalisé les entreprises a subi une
atteinte excessive de la même manière
que quatre ans plus tard il recherchera
si la propriété publique dont il nous
dit qu'elle bénéficiait l'oci d'une
protection constitutionnelle est mise en
cause d'une manière qui ne seraient pas
justifiées par une loi de privatisation
au cours des délibérés on s'en tenait
toujours à des arguments d'ordre
juridique arguments juridiques et
conséquences très politique certaines
décisions sont attendues scruter conspué
depuis le début de la pandémie un sujet
cristallise toutes les tensions dans la
rue dans les repas de famille comme dans
les mines ma part je suis favorable au
pass vaccinale mais je ne peux pas
cautionner un texte qui a pour objectif
d'emmerder les français à la pente à nos
libertés vous êtes trompés sur tout mac
nous ne respecte pas la constitution
fort au bord de l'abyme vous n'avez
qu'un mode horde faisons un grand pas
[Musique]
rue de montpensier en garde la tête
froide parer à toute éventualité
comme tous les lundis matin jean maya
secrétaire général du conseil réuni les
chefs de service comment on devait noter
l'annoncé de vendredi par le premier
ministre d'une nouvelle loi sanitaire
qui est d'avoir acheminé au parlement
d'ici la fin janvier quelque chose me
dit que alors qu'on pensait en avoir
terminé avec la loi sanitaire soit riche
nature de celles-ci aussi nous pourrions
connaître à mme jean maillard anticipe
le recours constitutionnel et prévient
les services d'une fort probable saisine
[Musique]
on
cet instant précis le sénat à réexaminer
texte on s'attend à ce que l'assemblée
nationale
adopte le texte demain lundi matin si
les informations sont exactes le conseil
sera saisie d' au moins un recours aux
photos bien vu le conseil est saisi par
61 députés au sujet de la loi du pass
vaccinale
[Musique]
la mécanique se met en route le greffe
du conseil réceptionne saisine et les
signatures alors on va vérifier leur
validité
jean mayacine enfin le document ce qui
valide son enregistrement
la fameuse saisine est alors envoyé aux
membres du conseil
[Musique]
ces enfants qui jouent notamment au
football ce doute est il que quelques
étages plus haut se joue le destin d'une
loi qui va régir nos vies
et là tout s'enchaîne ces deux services
juridiques qu'il incombe de plancher sur
les textes et de produire une note qui
servira la décision des neuf sages
toute cette symphonie juridique et
orchestré par jean maire le tempo est
une chose fondamentale et dure pas de
relâchement possible il faut tenir les
délais c'est aussi le croisement des
échéances qui rend palpitante mais
journée du secrétaire général cette
maison ne s'arrête jamais véritablement
ici la notion de continuité de l'état à
une certaine consistance
alors comment ça se passe concrètement
pour toute
décision je nomme un rapporteur
c'est à dire un membre parmi les sages
parmi les membres on a utilisé de
présentation mais parce que dans le
texte c'est bien l'obligation de
présenter un pass sera porteur étudie la
question attentivement et travaille avec
nos juristes et il élabore une décision
un projet de décision mais ce qu'il
faudrait pas juste peut-être simplement
même pas référence aux textes
applicables dire quand même que derrière
c'est une vraie obligation qui me tient
de qui a de vraies conséquences se
projette décision arrive devant notre
collège le rapporteur lille rapport
qu'il a préparé une fois qu'il a lu son
rapport et qu'il a présenté son projet
de décision nous en discutons la
discussion elle peut aussi durer entre
15 minutes et 5 heures aujourd'hui ces
deux heures alors de compte il parlait
loin de ma caméra
le thème principal c'est le pass
vaccinale
c'est quand même une grande mutation aux
libertés attentatoires aux libertés ça
ne peut ça veut dire qu'il ya toute une
série d'activités qu'on ne peut faire
que s'ils ont été vaccinées tout notre
travail consiste à voir si par rapport à
ces atteintes aux libertés elles sont
nécessaires proportionnée et adaptée ou
excessives par rapport à la protection
de la santé
attendez une seconde
la constitution et la loi fondamentale
qui fixe l'organisation et le
fonctionnement de l'état bon mais les
droits et libertés c'est la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen de
je croyais naïvement que le conseil ne
s'occupaient que de la constitution en
tout cas de gaulle le voyait ainsi le
conseil après une certaine liberté par
rapport au gouvernement
après le départ du général de gaulle le
conseil s'est émancipé il a étendu son
pouvoir en 1971 il ya eu un coup de
théâtre il a décidé de se mêler aux 6es
droits et libertés individuelles en 71
le conseil constitutionnel dit désormais
je vais plus simplement regarder la
conformité à l'aspect institutionnel de
la constitution je vais vérifier la
conformité de la loi avec les grands
principes du droit c'est à dire la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 le préambule de la
constitution de 1946 qui établit les
grands droits sociaux la liberté
d'association la liberté de la presse la
propriété privée le droit du travail et
ultérieurement la charte de
l'environnement et donc ça c'est la
chair du droit c'est ça qu'on appelle le
bloc de constitutionnalité
cette extension du périmètre de son
contrôle parce qu'en réalité c'est de
cela qu'il s'agit
va rendre le conseil constitutionnel
gardien des droits et libertés ce qui
n'était pas le cas auparavant bloc de
constitutionnalité en 71
élargissement de la saisine en 1974 avec
ces deux réformes majeures le conseil a
soit à discutable le mans sa légitimité
et françois mitterrand qui arrivent au
pouvoir en 1981 et malgré ces critiques
passé va composer avec l'institution oui
c'est très bien accommodé la bulle
présidentielle
la preuve fort de cette liberté tout
présidentielle il nomme à la présidence
du conseil robert badinter l'homme de
l'abolition de la peine de mort bada
terre va initier l'une des plus
importantes réformes constitutionnelles
de la vème république
je n'ai jamais cessé de vouloir
transformer cette institution
protectrice de la présidence de la
république et de la majorité gaullienne
on a une véritable cour
constitutionnelle
ce que l'on peut donner aux français
c'est le droit se prévaloir
individuellement de la création de ton
club
quand ils sont jugés ils peuvent dire
dans la loi est inconstitutionnelle
j'ai vendu l'idée amis theron en 89 si
l'on en croit le calendrier annoncé par
le président de la république c'est donc
demain qu'il devrait présenter ses
propositions de réforme de la
constitution la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel pourrait être étendue à
tous plaideur dans un procès c'est à
dire à tout citoyen que tout citoyen
cuche plaindre des noirs fille lui
semblera nuire à sa liberté le qpi
chacal dépenses au conseil
constitutionnel le sénat retoque lead et
votre contre il faudra attendre vingt
ans pour que l'exception
d'inconstitutionnalité
reviennent autre nom tout aussi barbare
je présiderai public le 1er mars 2010
restera comme une date importante
celle de l'entrée en vigueur de la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité qui va conférer à nos
concitoyens des droits nouveaux ce ne
sont pas simplement les lois futur déjà
votée mais pas encore promulguée qui
font l'objet d'une saisine mais toutes
les lois de france et de navarre et la
saisine c'est pas simplement c'est pas
les parlementaires c'est n'importe quel
justiciable devant n'importe quelle
juridiction c'est incontestablement une
avancée de l'état de droit
[Musique]
le conseil constitutionnel cherche à se
rapprocher du modèle juridictionnelle ne
serait-ce que alors que rien ne l'exigé
en prévoyant la tenue d'une audience
publique
avec la création d'une salle d'audience
qui ressemble beaucoup à une salle de
tribunal et donc avec j'allais dire
formellement et y compris sur le fond
l'application de règles qui sont celles
de la procédure juridictionnelle est
donc le conseil constitutionnel
du coup au lieu de prendre comme au
début cinq décisions ou comme après la
réforme ouvrant aux parlementaires
quinze ou vingt décision prend sans
décision par an applicables à toutes les
lois et à tous les domaines et qpc dès
lors qu'elles surviennent à l'occasion
de litiges met plus directement en
relation la constitution avec des
branches du droit et donc parmi les
membres du service juridique du conseil
constitutionnel il ya une attention qui
est portée au fait d'avoir deux très fin
connaisseur de la procédure pénale des
procédures fiscales de questions en lien
avec le droit de la famille bref toutes
les branches du droit qui peuvent être
au point de départ d'une question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité
exemple souvenez-vous en 2019 la
montagne d'or est un projet de mine à
ciel ouvert en guyane comme vata oblige
le gouvernement décide d'y renoncer
ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'à
l'heure actuelle ce que je sais du
projet n'est pas compatible avec
l'ambition de vieilles ficelles mais
mais mais le conseil d'état juge que le
gouvernement ne peut s'opposer
renouvellement de concessions accordées
par le code minier bataille des
associations de défense de
l'environnement sont vent debout on a
d'un côté un discours politique le
projet sera pas et la réalité juridique
ou en fait l'état est condamné à
renouveler les concessions peut-on
accorder automatiquement la prolongation
d'une concession minière sans une étude
préalable de l'impact sur
l'environnement le code minier c'qui la
charte de l'environnement dit peut-être
bien que non ils sont les effets sur
l'environnement d'une telle décision et
est ce que ces effets sont pris en
compte ou non pas ministration
l'association requérante avant que les
articles 1 2 3 et l'article 7 de la
charte de l'environnement
pour préparer la décision du conseil il
s'en suit une heure de débats juridiques
passionnés autour des articles 1 2 3 et
7 de la charte de l'environnement en
vost 14 cycles 2 et 3 ok surtout 1 et 3
l'article 20 lui dit chacun a le droit
de vivre dans un environnement équilibré
et respectueux de la sen et l'article 3
toute personne doit prévenir les
atteintes qu'elle susceptibles de porter
à l'environnement ou à défaut en limiter
les conséquences pour proposer au
conseil de déclaré ces dispositions
contraires
contraire la constitution
[Musique]
victoire pour les associations de
défense de l'environnement c'est la
première fois que le conseil
constitutionnel vient censuré une
disposition législative au visa de
l'article 1 et 3 de la charte de
l'environnement qui reconnaît le droit
de vivre dans un environnement sain
c'est vraiment donné de la substance à à
ses droits en fait constitutionnel parce
que si on les fait pas vivre si le
conseil constitutionnel ne peut pas se
prononcer dessus ça reste juste des
jolis mots dans un joli texte mais en
fait on n'en fait rien et ça donne pas
de substances en fait à la à la
constitution au quotidien
dans cette affaire c'est peut-être pas
évident mais la qpc est une vraie
révolution en mettant la constitution à
la portée de tous même mois le conseil
devient une vraie cour constitutionnelle
bien sûr
[Musique]
mais comment se déroule une audience qpc
quelles problématiques un justiciable
peut-il soulevé le conseil a tout prévu
pour expliquer sa mission à tous les
citoyens ils se déplacent de temps à
autre en région pour honorer son office
c'est donc à la cour d'appel de bourges
la plus petite de france que nous
retrouvons les neuf sages
aujourd'hui se tient une audience qpc
que la demande de coyote system c'est la
fameuse application des de la navigation
bouchon travaux contre de police rade à
quoi une histoire de bagnole ça devrait
parler au plus grand nombre nous nous
allons d'abord entendre m guillaume
projet qui est avocat au barreau de
paris qui représente la société coyote
system parti au caire ces services
apparu au début des années 2000
connaissent un grand succès puisqu'ils
sont aujourd'hui utilisées par plus de
20 millions d'automobilistes en france
chaque utilisateur a la possibilité de
signaler les événements de la route
comme un accident un véhicule à
contresens mais aussi un radar ou un
contrôle de police or le gouvernement a
fait voter une loi pour empêcher cela il
ne croit qu'à ta dit la diffusion de ces
signalements et alerte dans un périmètre
précis
concrètement quand une interdiction de
rediffusion sera prononcé les
utilisateurs ne pourront plus par
exemple signalé un accident un radar
dont un contre de prix
le représentant du gouvernement prend la
parole son tour et plaide contre coyote
system selon lui il contrevient or
certains aspects à la sécurité publique
aucune exigence constitutionnelle ni on
était méconnu je vous invite à déclarer
les dispositions des articles l 100
30-11 elles sont 30-12 du code de la
route conforme à la constitution bercy
alors y at il des questions
monsieur le grossier juppé pour
modification personnel quel est le
statut exact regard du code de la route
de l'appel de phare
c'est ce signalement ne sont évidemment
interdite par aucun texte par la
quantité de personnes touchées et
lorsque l'on fait un appel de phare on
ne prévient qu'une ou deux personnes et
quelques personnes que l'on croise sur
la route là où ces outils par le la
connexion qu'elles permettent sont
beaucoup plus puissants et ont un impact
qui est beaucoup plus fort que un simple
appel de phare sur la route
c'est long et c'est compliqué en tout
cas pour moi à la sortie je demande leur
impression à des étudiants en droit
alors qui veut commencer comment vous
avez senti sans le conseiller super il a
quand même c'est comme moquer de
l'argumentation de cet avocat jean
dussault commissaire gaulle annoncé
lundi des appels de phares que sont en
fait c'est pas voilà c'est dit si tu es
tu pour autant la logique est la même
piste le clown iott c'est juste un outil
c'est ça mais validation et je pense
d'ailleurs on en discutait entre nous je
pense à cette qpc sera concluante pour
la partie qui justement défendu je pense
à soi confions une semaine plus tard
laurent fabius retourne à bourges
expliqué et détaillé à des fins
pédagogiques
le délibéré à nos étudiants de la
faculté de droit j'ai compris que je
suis ici je reprends votre expression en
tant que chargé de td de luxe
dans ses griefs en fait il y en a un
sérieux les autres ne sont pas très
sérieux la société donc paullo 10 mai
d'accord la loi prévoit que le préfet a
pour interdire les communications etc
enfin il existe un principe qui est la
liberté de communication nous
considérons que on peut porter des
atteintes à la liberté de communication
mais à condition que ces athlètes soient
nécessaires
adaptées et proportionnées à l'objectif
poursuivi est notre décision dit
nécessaire oui
adapté oui mais proportionnée 1la est
quelque chose qui va pas autant la
teinte est justifié pour les routes
nationales puisque c'est près bien
précise et autant pour les routes
départementales
comme il n'ya pas de
limitation à ce que peut faire le préfet
l'a la tâte n'est pas proportionnée et
donc nous annulons la loire pour la
partie qui concerne les routes
départementales
depuis l'entrée en vigueur de la qpc ce
sont plus de 1000
si jean comme celle ci qui ont été
rendus elle confronte des lois obscurs
comme le code minier ou clair comme le
code de la route de grands principes
liberté fondamentale le conseil
constitutionnel renforce le risque dans
ses consolide l'état de trois gardiens
de l'ordre institutionnel il lui revient
donc historiquement d'être larbitre des
élections candidat à l'élection
présidentielle où il remplit plutôt
bonjour alors on est où des parrainages
parrainage on en est exactement à 168
promesses ce sont des promesses qu'on
récolte aujourd'hui donc à aujourd'hui
un matin et en fait on continue jusqu'au
4 mars je crois que c'est la date limite
du conséquence
les très fameux parrainage jusqu'en 1974
il n'en fallait que ce en mai 1976 une
loi va tout changer
pour être candidat à l'elysée il faudra
la caution de 500 par an provenant de 30
départements il s'agit on la devine est
de rendre plus difficiles les conditions
requises afin de faire obstacle aux
candidats fantaisistes ou marginaux
bonbons c'est en effet au conseil que
l'on collecte vérifie et valide les
parrainages il n'arrive pas poste chaque
matin pendant cinq semaines à partir de
la fin du mois de janvier
les parrainages arrive ici dans une
enveloppe particulière dont les au
louvre l'enveloppent on enlève le
parrainage
ont nommé lève dans cette partie par
candidat et après on numérote chacun des
formulaires c'est votre surnom dit non
l'homme au tampon bourillon
là on contrôle tout document parrainage
est arrivé ici on est capable de dire
combien on en a on en a reçu
une fois photocopier tamponné horodatées
les parrainages originaux sont mis au
coffre loin bien sûr de toute
intervention humaine
ensuite c'est le contrôle visuel c'est
une vérification des informations et non
la commune l'orthographe des candidats
le mandat des élus et les signatures
correspondant si tout va bien le
parrainage d'enregistrer validé par les
neuf sages et publiée sur le site du
conseil
les candidats installés au parti bien
installé avec beaucoup d'élus rapidement
à leurs parrainages mais pour les autres
les petits candidats la collecte est
beaucoup plus compliqué
la recherche de parrainages c'est un
véritable chemin de croix c'est
difficile il savait mobilise une énergie
et en nombre de personnes considérable
mais la difficulté principale à laquelle
on se heurte c'est que l'immense
majorité des maires ne souhaitent
parrainer personne et c'est mon cas
alors à laquelle je vous parle
j'approche les 400 signatures mais ce
n'est pas cinq cents si les maires ne
parraine pas dire a pas de diversité
politique imaginez que ni marine le pen
ni jean-luc mélenchon ni zemmour n'est
leur signature pour participer à cette
élection et vous croyez qu'on pourrait
dire on les exclut parce qu'il n'ya pas
des signatures j'observe que
il ya une discussion frénétique sur les
parrainages à un mois d'élections et que
ensuite pendant les cinq années qui
suivent on n'en parle plus en attendant
françois bayrou a une idée la banque dit
banques des parrainages des élus se
regroupent et se répartissent les
signatures pour parrainer des candidats
en difficulté
mais quand un parrainage litigieux une
enquête commence c'est le travail des
rapporteurs adjoint les airs à cela
contacter les élus ont vérifié les
conditions d'obtention du parrainage
à la suite
après avoir utilisé la banque des
parrainages c'est ça mais par contre
vous avez c'est vous qui avez signé le
vous avez signé alors que vous sachiez
que c'était alors que vous saviez pardon
que c'était pas de problème là dessus ça
a été en gros vous n'avez pas donné un
document blancs à remplir sans savoir
le parrainage considéré comme litigieux
passe alors entre les mains du
secrétaire général qui supervise les
opérations
[Musique]
sera présenté devant le collège pons le
collège puissante débattre
une dernière délibération
j'attends dehors ça devient une habitude
c'est la fin de la récolte dans quelques
instants les candidats parrainés seront
annoncés
[Musique]
ce matin conformément à notre
constitution et aux textes en vigueur le
conseil constitutionnel a arrêté la
liste officielle des candidates et
candidats pour l'élection à la
présidence de la république qui aura
lieu les 10 et 24 avril prochains
nathalie arthaud fabien roussel emmanuel
macron jean lassalle marine le pen eric
zemmour jean luc mélenchon anne hidalgo
yannick jadot valérie pécresse philippe
poutou nicolas dupont aignan la campagne
présidentielle peut commencer
pendant ce temps là au conseil
on se prépare à accueillir trois
nouveaux membres
c'est le même rituel tous les trois ans
la procédure de nomination au conseil
constitutionnel si une procédure qui
fait couler beaucoup d'encre et qui
donne lieu à beaucoup de débats depuis
1958 le débat il tient au fait que les
autorités nominations sont le président
de la république le président de
l'assemblée nationale et le président du
sénat on en vient à cette nomination
très critique et olivier au conseil
constitutionnel les deux autres
nominations faites également tiquer
certes
quelles que soient les critiques et
polémiques qu'il existe un contrôle
parlementaire
nous auditionnons ce matin madame
jacqueline gourault dont la nomination
en tant que membre du conseil
constitutionnel est proposée par le
président de la république si votre
commission et celle du sénat a tout à
l'heure l'approuvent je m'engagerai bien
sûr de toutes mes forces au sein de
cette institution cardinales de notre
république que warsmann madame elle je
dois vous dire que j'ai été très
impressionné quand j'ai lu votre cv je
voterai évidemment pour et je trouve que
vous avez un profil qui apportera
beaucoup à notre conseil cautionnait
jours maxi je vous remercie pour la go
le groupe la france a soumis ce monsieur
bernard ici je pense madame la ministre
que vous auriez dû refuser cette
proposition
peut-être que il n'y a pas de sujet de
compétences mais il ya un sujet
d'impartialité vous avez passez votre
temps à essayer de renier de pousser
dans ses retranchements dans ses limites
les plus ultimes le conseil
constitutionnel et politique ont
toujours été contre le conseil
constitutionnel certains d'entre eux ont
être se sont fait nommer pour limiter le
pouvoir il ya ceux et je n'en fais pas
partie qui considèrent qu'il ne faudrait
que des juristes au conseil
constitutionnel je pense qu'il est utile
d'avoir au conseil constitutionnel des
membres qui ont un regard sur la réalité
de l'action politique
8 mars 2022 les parlementaires ont voté
et trois nouveaux membres sont reçus à
l'elysée
ce jour-là un conseiller d'état une
magistrats une ministre rejoigne le club
très fermé des sages de la république
instant solennel
salutations très distinctes et
silence jacqueline gourault véronique
malbec françois ses nerfs je sais que
vous aurez à coeur de jouer ce rôle de
fantassins de notre démocratie jurés
vous de bien et fidèlement remplir vos
fonctions de les exercer en toute
impartialité dans le respect de la
constitution de garder le secret des
délibérations
et des votes
de ne prendre aucune position publique
et ne donner aucune consultation sur les
questions relevant de la compétence du
conseil sulfures
julie cher
je le jure acte sera dressé du serment
que vous venez de prêter devant le
président de la république et devant le
conseil constitutionnel
[Applaudissements]
serment prêté trois membres entrent au
conseil constitutionnel et services
rendus trois sages sans vent la
continuité de l'état de droit s'est
assuré
je garderai toujours un souvenir
absolument formidable de ces données
pendant lesquelles non seulement je ne
me suis pas ennuyé mais vous avez tous
enrichi ma vie
la diversité de nos parcours de nos
expériences de nos personnalités ici au
sein du conseil c'est vraiment la
richesse la richesse et la force du
conseil constitutionnel qu'il ya des
choses qui subsistent au delà des
changements de personnes c'est à dire
que d'une certaine manière les murs du
conseil constitutionnel porte une
histoire
le conseil constitutionnel a une âme
une âme louis des mémoires sous des
combles du quatrième étage
la bibliothèque du conseil un bond
trésor juridique
de
la revue générale de droit international
public obscur et pointu lecture qui sont
de véritables socle de référence pour
les sages maintenant il est temps de
faire place nette c'est ici que sont
stockés les milliers de procès verbaux
du premier tour de l'élection qui nous
occupe en effet sept conseils de
contrôler le bon déroulement du scrutin
le conseil constitutionnel a examiné
l'ensemble des procès verbaux de
recensement transmis par les services de
l'état et nous avons pris connaissance
des rapports de nos 2000 délégués nous
allons procéder au redressement de
certains résultats et à la rectification
d'erreur matérielle et nous avons
examiné les protestations et des
réclamations qui nous ont été adressés
[Musique]
les résultats obtenus par les 12
candidats sont les suivants par ordre
croissant de nombre de suffrages
nathalie arthaud 0 56% des suffrages
exprimés philippe poutou 0 76% à nidal
go
1,74 % nicolas dupont aignan 2 0 6%
fabien roussel
2,28 % jean lassalle 3,13 % yannick
jadot
4,63 % valérie pécresse
4,78 % des suffrages exprimés eric
zemmour
7,0 7% jean-luc mélenchon
21,95 % marine le pen
23,15 % emmanuel macron
27,85 % des suffrages exprimés
les deux candidats arrivés en tête du
premier tour sont donc emmanuel macron
bonsoir et marine le pen soir
et voici le fameux débat de l'entre-deux
tours mais attention l'un des candidats
souhaite réviser la constitution afin de
limiter les droits fondamentaux à
certains citoyens à écouter ses
propositions l'expulsion des criminels
et des délinquants étrangers suppression
du droit du sol parce que je pense que
la nationalité française s'hérite ou se
mérite priorité nationale interdiction
de la régularisation des clandestins
modification du droit d'asile tel ou tel
candidat voudrait modifié des aspects
fondamentaux de la constitution
française le droit d'asile liberté etc
or si on veut réviser ces aspects là
changer donc la constitution
il faut utiliser les procédures qui
prévoient comment on révise la
constitution dans mon référendum sur
l'immigration il y à une révision
constitutionnelle iaas attendre de
choses qui rentrent dans la constitution
et je passerai par l'article dont je les
dis très clairement
comme le général de gaulle l'a fait en
62 comme il l'a défendu après 62 en
effet le général encore et toujours
avait brandi l'article 11 de la
constitution pour faire son référendum
sur l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel mais
tout ça est est il bien constitutionnel
quoi qu'il en soit une menace plane au
dessus de l'état de droit en 1962 le
général de gaulle décide en violation de
la constitution disons le d'organiser un
référendum pour réviser la constitution
en court-circuitant complètement le
parlement on ne peut réviser la
constitution que selon une procédure qui
fait intervenir le parlement mais
certains candidats dur non non non ça ne
va pas il faudrait que ce soit seulement
le peuple qui décide le référendum
direct c'est contraire aux dispositions
actuelles de la contribution aujourd'hui
un président de la république avait la
tentation d'utiliser la même procédure
que le général de gaulle vient
vraisemblablement le conseil
constitutionnel pourrait attirer
l'attention sur le fait qu'il ya une
irrégularité dans la procédure parce que
la loi a pour objet de réviser la
constitution et que la voix qui est
prévu pour ce faire
est un autre article que celui qui avait
été utilisé en 1962 et qui pourraient
l'être ici donc peu importe le résultat
du scrutin le conseil veille
rue de montpensier vous souffrez pas
pour la dernière ligne droite le
contrôle et la validation du scrutin
final
[Musique]
et oui c'est une réélection il faut
néanmoins vérifier tous les procès
verbaux et statuer sur les incidents de
ce second scrutin avant la proclamation
définitive des résultats
et des incidents il y en a eu 21 très
exactement
il y en a un plus médiatisé que les
autres dans sa commune jean lassalle
s'abstient et le fait savoir au monde
entier
grave
cette année
la réponse du conseil est sans appel par
son comportement monsieur la salle à
porter atteinte au respect dû à la
dignité des opérations électorales outre
les sanctions pénales potentiellement
encourus et suffrages exprimés dans ces
communes sont analysés
[Musique]
conseil constitutionnel en ce 27 avril
2000 bahts 2 proclame monsieur emmanuel
macron élu président de la république le
président réélu ne devrait donc jamais
tu disais ce fameux article 11 pour
réviser la constitution
mais le quinquennat qui vient de
s'achever l'esa pays divisé fracturé
dans lequel l'extrême droite bat un
nouveau record de voix ainsi la
cérémonie de réinvestiture et sobre
grave au nom du conseil constitutionnel
je vous exprime toutes mes félicitations
le temps de votre premier mandat
a été notamment percuté par une
accumulation de
crise avec notamment
un certain
malaise démocratique préoccupant
je compléterai volontiers par ces mots
si de victor hugo
en ces temps troublés
soyons les serviteurs du droit et les
esclaves du devoir
servir le droit c'est d'abord évidemment
respecter l'état de droit
ce patrimoine précieux de principes
essentiels à nos démocraties et à notre
république y compris
si la constitution elle même devait être
révisé oui cet état de droit si fragile
doit être préservée à tout prix même
s'il serait tentant d'y faire quelques
entorses face aux menaces qui planent
on ne doit pas sacrifier quelques
libertés pour une supposée sécurité
c'est toute la mission des cours
constitutionnelles dans le monde et du
conseil constitutionnel dans notre pays
à paris et dans toute la france se
déroule la nuit du droit chaque 4
octobre date anniversaire de la
constitution de 1958
nisy pour rappeler à chacune et à chacun
l'importance des droits et des libertés
fondamentales dans cette date agnel du 4
octobre 58 était important de je dirais
oui de répondre par l'affirmative pour
pour être là pour rappeler notre lien à
l'état de droit dans des moments
compliqués où il a été particulièrement
sollicités je pense notamment à la
pandémie pourquoi parce que la pandémie
c'est une mise en suspension très
souvent de l'état de droit donc de
redire à quel point notre lien est
constant et que même si tu veux la
manière dont nous faisons nous dans
l'état de droit des états d'exception
ces étapes d'exception sont quand même
régi par l'état de droit donc sage à
n'importe quoi faire n'importe quoi donc
je pense que c'était important de le
redire et de le redire parce que tu
entends tous les jours des cris
d'orfraie considérant que mon dieu nous
sommes dans le pire des états
liberticide d'ithaque dictatorial et
cetera dont je pense qu'il était
intéressant de rappeler que non la
séparation des pouvoirs
l'indépendance de la justice
le respect du principe de l'égalité
voilà quelques éléments de base de cet
état de droit qui est malheureusement on
le verra et bafoué dans de nombreuses
parties du monde et parfois même en
europe nous ici c'est la démocratie
c'est l'état de droit
les pays démocratiques doivent prouver
que ce ne sont pas juste des lois et
qu'ils sont prêts à agir pour aider les
autres pays à accéder à cette démocratie
25 ans
je m'ai bas pour cet état des droits
finalement les droits les victimes de
violences sexuelles puissent avoir gain
de cause surtout dans la région où je
travaille si on travaille dans un
contexte où l'état de droit n'existe pas
a finalement on a le sentiment dit de
toujours recommencée faire la même chose
oui un combat sans fin partout dans le
monde où cet état de droit n'existe pas
hélas encore
un combat aussi pour le protéger dans
nos démocraties
ce que c'est que la liberté
il est vrai que dans les démocraties
le peuple paraît faire ce qu'il veut
mais la liberté politique ne consiste
points à faire ce que l'on veut
dans un état c'est à dire dans une
société où il y a des lois
la liberté ne peut consister cas pouvoir
faire ce que l'on doit vouloir
et à n'être point contraint de faire ce
que l'on ne doit pas vouloir
il faut se mettre dans l'esprit ce que
c'est que l'indépendance est ce que
c'est que la liberté
la liberté est le droit de faire tout ce
que les lois permettent
et si un citoyen pouvait faire ce
qu'elles défendent
ils n'auraient plus de liberté parce que
les autres auraient tout de même ce
pouvoir
[Musique]